[Music]
in smart jeans news oh I got a lot of
those really in your closet all stacked
up made by summertime baby summertime
summertime summertime maybe we can [ __ ]
summertime summertime
Lana Dori one yeah that's not see that's
older than that a study has found that
genetics plays a stronger role in
determining academic success than
previously thought
oh yeah dog ages do the best genetically
predetermined to be the [ __ ] a
student oh so you're talking
academically smart then yeah cuz when it
comes to social smarts therefore no no
no this article I am so they're not
they're not socially dumb in Asia I
almost caught it
go ahead that's true they're socially
done here they're not socially dominator
it's okay to pee on your kids over there
man yeah so this takes place in the UK
this study here and so they're saying
that Elementary School has virtually no
effects as genetics determine academic
success so because it's not challenging
enough well they're saying that like the
type of school a kid goes to has little
impact on their academic achievement so
like you know how parents are so you
know like oh they have to have like the
best elementary waiting list
I gotta beg to differ like a
[ __ ] I'm from personal personal
experience so like for example I went to
I grew up in Cerritos so which is or
just which is like a regular school to
me and over there just the requirements
to graduate are a little bit higher so
you have to take algebra to to graduate
like everything elementary school I know
just the high school but but the
pipeline to that already prepares you
for that first and I was like CDF
student
and when I came here to mark kept all
their requirement is you only need
Algebra one
so because of that all the elementary
schools they only prepare you like the
the the preparation is just way low
because everything is the pipeline that
leads up to the high school and when I
came up to here there's like hell of
people I don't even know how to spell as
like a sophomore and junior high like
everyone I just thought was fin locking
stupid as [ __ ] and I'm just like do like
I'm like you know what Asian fobs come
here and they think that curriculum is
[ __ ] easy yeah I was an F student
over there and I wasn't even trying to
smash in the grades here and I'm just
like dude this is oh no I would much
rather have my kid be a straight [ __ ]
and in a good school district then to
kill it in like the worst school just
because I just think there isn't be
better prepared I mean when I came to
Monterey Park I was like wow these
people are really smart and they do
their home that's a huge difference so
are they saying that it doesn't matter
where you go to school in kindergarten
is what affects you academics a baby
school well with the talking about is
like apparently they have like these
selective schools or and non-selective
schools there's a magnet school or maybe
we don't know that you think UK system
that I'm like try and understand what
they're talking about here but
apparently they have like the way that
they admit kids is like based on certain
criteria and usually it's like academic
criteria and they're saying that for
this specific study they didn't find a
difference between the selective and
non-selective grammar schools in terms
of academic success of course yes school
is gonna be important but they're just
talking about that genetics plays a big
role in these I believe in that though
the genetic wizard plays a huge and
they're also even going as far as to say
that they feel that genetics should be
included in teacher training courses and
they should actually look at genetic
background yep the Asians just give them
harder math problems already I don't fit
that I'm a outlier man [ __ ] I think some
people are they're better at structured
learning way better like people just
they love it they can kill
that I'm just like [ __ ] this man I can't
deal with this shall I go outside people
start the teachers start talking in and
I'm like vlog do you what the [ __ ] why
is it making me so sleepy how'd you do
that in college though I killed it in
college yeah but that's different
what do you mean we stimulated
differently like yeah because the
teachers werden different like I think
they were more engaged they cared about
the [ __ ] that they were talking about
and it was just a different environment
what kind of environment do you learn
the best under when I teach myself
because people don't have patience for
me huh how would you teach yourself I
think I learned the best when I care
about what I'm learning about so you
could do home study yeah you could do
online classes yeah I get obsessed over
things that I like and I can spend 24
hours on it and then I can't wait to
wake up early so I could do it again and
I'm I can't I don't know how you guys
are but I cannot do home study and
online it's like I can't I need like to
be I need to talk to people I need
someone to tell me if I have a question
you know what I mean like the same I
want to be I want to be good at that I
think I learned the best when it's like
things where I can see that hey doing
this you can get better at this and
there's a benefit behind it so like I
loved math once I started loving
business and understanding money and
accounting and all that stuff implement
I'm like very you though that's why I
like we get into those like [ __ ] the
rabbit hole you know you like something
and we learn it to the [ __ ] extent
yep I obsess over it well how do you
think you would learn better as a kid
then like what kind of teaching style I
think if my parents were better at
explaining how this can lead to this so
like they thought I was talking back so
they got angry at me but I was just
curious so I would ask them like so why
do I have to go to school and they like
to get a job and I'll go why do you need
a job
and I'm not giving them attitude I'm
just trying to understand the overall
economic structure why does this happen
it's by but when you're a child you
don't understand like because because
they didn't think about it
why they don't know yes
yeah they don't have an answer cuz I was
trying to say at that time I think I was
in like third grade or something like
that like why do we need money and why
is this something that people need to
have in order to survive because there's
groups out there like you would learn
about in the ends and you will learn
about you know people living in the
jungle and I'm like how come they don't
need it but we need it right but they
can't you know you can't articulate that
as a child right but if those answers
are not satisfied I dismiss it and I
don't even deal with it and I don't
listen you maybe you want a [ __ ]
dumbass kid I want a dumb kid but
there's a question anything dude this
okay and then I'm like thank God I love
this child have you guys heard of Manas
as the Montecito way of learning
Montessori yes thank you thank you I
wasn't a Bella way over my mellow
learning graffiti on the wall so I feel
like this wasn't this wasn't around when
my daughter twenty years ago but now
they allow kids to learn on their own
and they ask and they explore and like
it's that thing where you know if they
are graduating from The Cribs the bed
you kind of put it in there and and let
them walk around and it's not like you
know we all had those like the big cage
thing that would you know they kind of
learned on their own which I think you
would have been amazing in theirs
Montessori schools like all over the
place yeah one thing I read about that
thought it was pretty tight was they
believe in learning not in just your age
group because they think that stifles
your learning so it's age groups it's
not it's like a age range so if you're
five you're with kids that are three and
seven because then you can learn things
from like the older kids are a little
bit more experienced and you can help
teach younger kids so just like a better
social environments pretty cool I don't
think it's new but there's Montessori
schools all over the place but like when
you do like martial arts and stuff like
you feel that like as like a little
eight-year-old kid like I was doing
martial arts and I already felt
leadership by teaching the five-year-old
kid so as a little kid already
developing leadership skills and social
skills and stuff like that that you
don't get to experience just being a
third grader because everyone's the same
you learn the most by teaching hmm did
you put your a private school Montessori
mm-hmm
it's a method I think most of them are
private school but there it's everywhere
now though like every every city has at
least one or two these guys I just want
my kid to be a butterfly chaser
then they'll still stake you forever
you I have to speak the headphones not
in his views but in his nose now I
remember being younger and going with my
mom to one of those schools to check it
out for my brothers and like they even
have like cameras in the classrooms and
make sure like the parents feel like you
didn't get into the school they
shouldn't thank you for those schools no
I haven't been around which like they
can log in and see what's happening in
the classroom yeah yeah that's well
that's some helicopter access to it I
just remember all I'm saying like that's
so expensive and I'm just like okay I
won't even consider it or like when I go
ahead I think I'm I don't way to broke
so they even look into that I know dude
[ __ ] your kids right no but I mean
thanks to this study here that it just
shows that you don't need a selective
school with the best teachers and the
best everything cuz it really doesn't
impact as much as genetics do so well
I'm just gonna assume it's very
defeating got my stupid genes so I'm
just gonna put them in like as many good
things as possible you guys will look
into putting over shirts I mean I just
like just even when like you take karate
at like the Boys and Girls Club YMCA
when you have like a lesbian like
teacher trying to teach you karate first
I learned I learned karate from like a
lady that looks like she should be a
lunch lady but she learns I should be a
cafeteria teacher lady
and then if you go to a school that is a
pipeline to the Olympics just one year
and there it's just way different and
it's just yeah the quality of school
like I can go to caliber I could
probably like a yellow box and go out
there and just run that school like I
run all the kids just the caliber of
people that you surround yourself with
because like I grew up in East LA right
like my house is located there but then
I was going at a better school district
and just talking to the people within my
community I was just like
she like I'm not trying to sound smarter
than you but like you guys are [ __ ]
trash it wasn't like that but like the
dislike like the difference of like my
like the conversations I had versus what
they were having it was oh I asked
fourth-grade to like you know tenth
grade and I'm like oh you can see the
feeling not at the age of eight you were
like tutoring like a 13 year old boy
machine I mean it was just being so
basically they're saying it doesn't
matter the genetics that's gonna
overrule all on how well they do at
school I didn't have dumb DNA then your
kid's gonna be done don't wait on trying
to get because my kid that was on
economics they said that I'm slowest
they said that the intelligence and
development of a child has nothing to do
with all those preparatory classes or
anything but it's more likely that they
will be successful because the behavior
of the parents so the type of parents
that send their kids to these things
they're really involved or they're
really like goal driven and all that
stuff so the kids pick up on that and
that is that contributes way more than
the kid go into these special schools
but they're absent parents working all
the time yeah yeah that was on
Freakonomics it said the same thing I
like that what could they do there is so
it's still too early to tell
like how much yeah I know we're putting
this video but don't take it don't get
take my word for it it's pretty much
just for then it's easy dude you just
got to pretend like you're smart around
your kids dude and then you're just I'm
just going to have a monocle and a
[ __ ] pipe around me all the time
it's my name's Bob hello Archibald I've
seen the stupidest people in the world
still be successful so it doesn't even
matter what I'm saying it doesn't even
matter
[Music]